I'm upset by your persistence
Snow approaches in front of my wife, and I can raise my insensitivity
That's what I think I understand Just by knowing your feelings
I know it's difficult,
but I can't hold back the feeling I
have  It's not Kiryu's secret technique, but I've been saying for a long time that I want to take care of him.
There's a lot of these too,
that's the
starting point Don't let anyone else do it It's
not just these two
Mai's obsession with snow
Shinsoichi I'm not dealing with anyone
It's a cat Hey, you're a
fool
Snow should know the concentration
This tournament ended when he was a woman of Sabji The
story is over
Snow won too much and said the same thing
[music]
Kill
Everyone
sleeper bena
[music]